something big is coming to Pangu Island
never give up on being awesome gnarling
put them together for the Hang five the
most extreme team surfing the earth and
living the dream Wow
the hey've I've seen them surf made me
who I am today what's up little dudes
uh-oh its whoo-hoo you're the awesomest
from Sony Pictures animation and WWE
Studios JC Undertaker Hunter Paige and
mr. McMahon are putting Cody and his
friends to the ultimate test this is a
map to the most legendary surfing spot
on the flat it's a surfers graveyard to
ride the most dangerous waves on earth
you got to do more than surfing you got
a survivor she's my one big chance to
get off Pangu and make something to
myself they're taking them under their
wings
if you wipeout up here you'll be a
bucket of extra crispy oh man don't eat
me I'm not the food to help them
overcome their fears I can't watch this
is the moment we've been waiting for
hold on and discover the meaning of
teamwork we have each other's back no
matter what
Surf's Up to wave media
blegh pressing a large heavy boulder
then on to a one-handed handstand all
while still leg pressing the boulder
you
[Music]
it all started with one thing
now Cody maverick chicken Joe and Lonnie
are teaming up with the Hang five the
most extreme dream team on earth WWE
superstars John Cena Undertaker Triple H
Paige and mr. McMahon
whatever it is they're about to do I
want to be a part of it
it's an old new movie from Sony Pictures
animation and WWE Studios I make this
look good oh man don't eat me I'm not
the food Surf's Up dude wave mania oh
why are you standing here next to me
I'll go talk to her man no I'm not gonna
talk to you so you gonna show hold you
crack oh thanks
all right well this is the third time
you've been unconscious this week I just
don't think it's very good for your
brain okay
oh yeah yeah that was awesome huh Qi
saved his life and all that was just
unbelievable really you here for the
surf contest uh I'll be watching you
really you'll be watching me well yeah
from the lifeguard station oh you know
yet not yet my gosh right that's your
job
hey you're gonna kiss her what yeah come
on Jill we got a dude you were saying
you're in love naughty all right look he
really did is he like you know see
though yeah I love my job
I'm an amazing job just this week with
the contest coming up at all to look
crazy you really have to be extra extra
attentive you have so many guys in the
water you came as a thing but you know
what I have a perfect record I've never
lost anybody sure there's been close
calls Oh
you